[Music]
all right as the battle that we're
fighting here against the virus rages in
the US and around the world our
adversaries China Russia and Iran are
taking advantage of the global pandemic
to weaken Western democracies and
disinformation against us let's bring in
the four-star general senior strategic
military commander General Jack keen
general what is uh what are Russians and
chill what is Russia and trying to do on
the intelligence end to to hurt us yeah
well let me first say all three of these
countries it's only exploding cobia 19
at our expense but none of their
activities are putting us on a path to
major confrontation I want to ensure our
audience about that first of all this
information is is one of their mainstays
and and that and that is they want to
undermine the people's trust in their
government they're also pushing back on
the sanctions that have been imposed on
one and removed based on the
humanitarian effect of kovat 19 and the
other thing is they're underscoring the
fact that the United States has the
largest out brett of kovat 19 and that's
due largely to the incompetence of the
United States government that is what is
surrounding their disinformation
campaign you're also posturing in terms
of trying to create goodwill in terms of
their rhetoric but also delivering
supplies and equipment and people
particularly Russia China Iran is not
involved in it to other countries and
then the last thing they do in Russia
has tied up the president in Ukraine a
little bit because of kovat 19 in the
focus he has to have on his country he
got him to agree to negotiate with
Russian proxies for the first time but
interesting enough the people balked on
it and Iran is posturing here to take
advantage of what they believe the
United States has turned inward and I
think that is why the United States
picked up on a plan for them to conduct
a large-scale attack inside Iran inside
Iraq excuse me it may have been thwarted
by the president's acknowledging that
that was in the planning stage and and
also China because Taiwan has been so
successful dealing with Kovic
tene and they've been critical of
mainland China they've upped all of
their military activities around Taiwan
but then again I want to say that none
of these activities put us on any path
to major conflict or war with the
exception of possibly some limited
conflict with Iran which would not lead
to war so that's what they're trying to
say but let's tell look at reality
China's look may be experiencing a
second wave number one number two the
Russians act like they they don't really
have a coronavirus problem they got a
huge problem and then Vladimir Putin has
already paid the price in what respect
well yeah Colvin 19 is hitting Russia
like it is any other country and of
course they're their divin with his is
absolutely uneven they haven't marshaled
all the resources of their government
and private sector of the way the United
States has in coping with it growing
unrest in the country in April President
Putin was supposed to have a referendum
of consolidation which would give him
the presidency indefinitely he has now
called that off because the popularity
for President Putin is tanking and and
that obviously is a good thing as far as
the United States is concerned because
Putin gets up every morning trying to
put a finger in the eye of the United
States the other thing is Iran is saying
hey world we have the u.s. released the
sanctions we're getting killed here by
the coronavirus should we
no absolutely not look if we offered
them humanitarian aid Brian and they and
they turned it down we've got to keep
our foot on on the pedal here with
sanctions and there's one sanction that
we we we should impose and we have given
relief to Russian nuclear power
companies Ross Adams namely and and the
reason is is dealing with the nuclear
power plants and the reason is the
United States is dependent on foreign
uranium and particularly Russian uranium
we should impose sanctions on Ross Adams
and others like that we should
absolutely close the door on the
Iranians Iranians have never been on
their heels as much as they are now
we've got to keep the pressure on them
at least in my lifetime and finally when
it comes to reopening our economy
there's some principals in the military
that you want to bring forward that
could help us into the civilian world
show flexibility shall persevere
perseverance and de-centralized the
execution so for example what happens in
Philadelphia won't exactly be needed in
Charlotte North Carolina correct yeah
that's absolutely right different places
different times changing situation you
have to have flexibility to adapt to a
changing situation assess the risk and
then execute vigorously perseverance is
about overcoming the impediments the
obstacles setbacks and failures but you
persevere nonetheless and you have to
have the spine to overcome your fear
because you're never going to be able to
make decisions based on perfect
information there's always risk involved
and we'll see that as we begin to make
decisions about putting people back to
work
there's only risk involved in that there
likely would still be some spread
involved until we absolutely get a
vaccine to shut it down but nonetheless
we've got to make those decisions and be
strong emotionally to get through this
because it's all unprecedented General
Jack keen thanks for putting it all in
perspective have a great weekend